everyone likes Paul Rudd he might be the
perfect movie star he leads a hit Marvel
franchise yet he seems down-to-earth he
broke through in the classic 90s teen
comedy clueless before becoming one of
the comedy cool kids with wet hot
American summer and anchorman before
segue into superhero mode as ant-man
Rudd likes to laugh and keep it light so
it's no surprise that he generates a lot
of bloopers and to offer hilarious proof
we've taken a deep dive to bring you
some of the funniest moments from behind
the scenes of his biggest movies just
some kid stuff what makes little kids
freak out in a good way more than
anything else being present for stuff
they think they're not supposed to see
for example bad words they've been told
their entire lives that some words must
never be said so it only stands to
reason that when they actually hear one
they become enthusiastically amused like
in this outtake from ant-man
got it I heard you why robot judd apatow
likes to keep things loose and
collaborative on his sets and since Paul
Rudd has an agile comic mind he's wound
up in a few of Apatow movies including
the 40 year old virgin his character
works alongside Steve Carell at a
big-box electronic store which gives the
actors plenty of opportunity to play
with goofy gadgets in this not quite
appropriate for the final cut sequence
Rudd interrupts a conversation to show
off a cool robot toy black market
panther in anchorman a movie full of
hilarious sequences one of the best
occurs when a stand iego reporter and
self-proclaimed ladies man Brian Fantana
shows off his stash of intoxicating
colognes to Ron Burgundy the prize of
his collection sex panther they've done
studies you know 60% of the time it
works every time
that doesn't make sense this outtake the
elaborate Panther shaped mechanical prop
doesn't work at all it's cost me $13,000
it really pisses me off knocking a few
back to the future pretending to be
intoxicated improvising lines and doing
either of those things while a co-star
is angrily yelling into your ear can't
be easy but Ruud manages all three of
those tasks in this unused seen from
knocked up while his character gets
progressively more drunk in a restaurant
he slurs and stumbles through some back
to the future themed goofy I'm gonna
build you know I'm gonna build you a
skateboard I want to see what you do in
the town square the future trust me
I'm going go to the twins Oaks Mall that
used to be the cracking up is only
natural the 2012 comedy wanderlust
concerns a big-city couple so sick of
urban annoyances that they decide to try
life on a nature positive free love
hippie style commune in this outtake
Paul Rudd tries to convince Jennifer
Aniston that they need to give up
natural life I don't think we're
supposed to be in a place where people
are hairier than Alec Baldwin's forearms
many apologies mr. Baldwin rolling right
along in the 2008 comedy role models
Paul Rudd and Sean William Scott play a
couple of guys forced into community
service all that stress highlights the
differences between the two resulting in
a fight which created a few unusable
outtakes this disc this coming from a
guy who likes girls a whole bunch when
to call cut in 2010 Rudd starred
opposite Reese Witherspoon in how do you
know where he plays a nice guy named
George who gets caught up in a federal
investigation of his father's company he
also finds time to fall in love
George is more than a bit nervous and
judging by this blooper those traits
seeped into rudd psyche I'm gonna tell
you exactly I'm gonna lick out
everything that I have inside Oh kiss
one kiss nuts to you what a schmuck
Dinner for Schmucks is an odd comedy
about odd people it stars Rudd as a guy
caught up with a strange Club that
requires guests to bring an oddball
along to regular dinner parties his
candidate is a weirdo named Barry played
by Steve Carell while shooting one
particular scene things got slightly
weirder than expected popcorns ready I
was just I was just microwaving some hot
pockets
[Music]